Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank"...
Who's ready to drink topless?
Drink topless?
Who's ready to
take a bite of...
Both: The Pizza Cupcake?
Mamma mia!
Who wants to put a beatdown
on some bacteria?
‐What are your sales?
‐$1.6 million.
‐What?
‐Yes, sir.
‐Whoo!
You're skating
on really thin ice.
I'm not afraid
of competition.
We all had trouble
using it.
It didn't work.
But we have a plan, and we know
how to execute our plan.
Man, you guys
are the real deal.
There's really
great synergy.
I'm going to
make you an offer.
‐Ouch.
‐It's like a mob offer.
You fell into
a money pit.
Does it grow hair?
♪♪
Narrator: First into the tank
is bedding made for
a specific consumer.
♪♪
What's up, Sharks?
My name is Wen.
I'm from St. Paul, Minnesota.
I'm here seeking $212,000
for 10% of my company,
Jax Sheets.
Pop quiz ‐‐ How often
do you think single men
on average wash their bedsheets?
Once a week?
‐Never. Never.
‐Once a month?
No.
On average, single men
only wash their bedsheets
every three months.
‐Ew.
‐No way.
That's right.
It's so gross.
Like, their pillowcases,
like, thousands and thousands
and thousand times more dirty
than a toilet seat.
That's why I had to make
Jax Sheets,
the first bedsheets for men.
Nasty, sweaty, stinky men,
who, like Mark in college,
would probably sleep
on anything.
[ Laughs ]
Our unique blend
of bamboo‐copper
allows Jax Sheets
to stay fresh for longer.
So if you forget
to wash your sheets
for a year or two,
no one has to know.
But wait, guys,
there's more.
Today only,
get a two‐for‐one special,
which includes my HercLéon line
of laundry‐free clothing.
You can travel, camp,
and experience more
while packing less.
So, Sharks, who wants to put
a beatdown on some bacteria
and get in bed with Jax?
‐Oh, my gosh.
‐I love the name Jax Sheets.
And you guys have samples
there of the Jax Sheets,
debut edition.
That is silk
and bamboo and copper.
So we used our Jax Sheets
bamboo‐copper,
and we fused it
with the silk.
This feels really good.
Okay, so is this
a commercially available
copper‐infused cloth?
From us, yes.
We're currently going
through a process
to get a patent
on our materials.
So, Wen, what you're
offering us today
is really two companies.
Yeah.
A sheet company.
And a T‐shirt company.
Yeah, with the underlying that
they're both
the same technology,
it's just that
different applications.
Are you saying it's the same
material in the T‐shirt?
No, it's not identical,
but it's the same,
like, research,
same technology, same concept.
The copper infusion.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So the point is
copper‐infused fabrics
that get rid of odor or bacteria
and keep it fresher longer.
Yes.
Yes. So, I went to Iceland,
took a little vacation,
and what I learned was that
my ‐‐ my polyester shirts
and my cotton shirts
were getting smelly
at different rates.
And I got confused by that.
Like, why is one shirt
so smelly already
and the other one
is still smelling pretty decent?
I can make it work
for two or three days.
How'd that
work out for you?
It ‐‐ It didn't work out
too well.
[ Laughter ]
Not very well.
I started learning as much
as I could about materials,
and I learned about bamboo,
I learned about copper,
I learned about silver,
and then I released a shirt
and everyone loved it.
And then after that they said,
"Hey, what about sheets?
The material of
the shirt's good.
Let's do some sheets too."
I'm like, "I'm down.
Why not?
Let's do some sheets."
That's kind of
how I got where I ‐‐
You know what? It's smart
because it's a huge market.
You're making a niche
out of that market.
Wen, are you selling these
today?
Yeah. So these just came out
on Kickstarter in November.
It sold $350,000.
Those are your total sales?
For this one, yes.
‐Of sheets.
‐Good for you.
Just of sheets.
So you're on Kickstarter.
Yeah.
And how much
did you ask for?
I asked for ‐‐
I think it was $10,000.
And you got
to $350,000.
Yes.
Wow.
I was sleeping through the
beginning of this presentation
'cause I thought
you had no sales.
I'm glad.
I hope you're rested.
I'm awake now.
I'm awake now
because you have sales, okay?
Do you know what it costs you
to acquire a customer?
Yeah.
The customer acquisition cost ‐‐
I got a little sheet here
just for you ‐‐
[ Cuban laughs ]
...was $33.
$33.
And what's the average sale?
The average sale is $148.
And what do you make on $148?
What's your margin?
Our margin's
about like $70.
So you spend $33
to get $70.
Yeah. I mean,
that was before COVID.
Now, it's ‐‐ I mean, it's ‐‐
What's it now?
Well, I can't sell
'cause I'm sold out.
Wen, you sold everything in
November, December of last year.
Yeah. Yeah.
When did you actually
ship it all?
Four weeks ago.
It took forever
to get them done.
Have you sold any sheets other
than through crowdsourcing?
No, no, because I didn't have
the inventory
and I was worried about
making sure I can deliver
before I can start taking up
more responsibilities.
And the shirts, did we touch
on that yet, on how many ‐‐
Not yet.
O'Leary:
Why don't you burn those?
Why are you
selling T‐shirts?
You can't make any money
doing that.
I might.
What are your sales
for the shirts?
So I just released the shirts'
co‐pairing, which is underwear,
and so this year
we've made $270,000.
And how did you
sell those?
On our website.
Your ask is $212,000
for 10%, correct?
Yes.
Why wasn't it $200,000
or $225,000?
$212,000?
You want to know the real answer
to that question?
Yeah.
No, lie to him.
Let's hear a great answer.
It's your lucky number ‐‐
I know it.
Lie to me.
No, it's because I couldn't say
$200,000 without stuttering,
so I had to find a number that
I could say without stuttering.
Because once I stuttered,
the whole thing,
I'm going to forget.
So that's kind of why.
That's a great answer.
That's it?
You're an honest guy, man.
That is ‐‐
I don't lie.
I'm sorry.
So who's running this company
with you?
It's just me, myself,
in my garage
just hanging out, you know,
with my lawn chair.
That's great.
Yeah, that's ‐‐ that's ‐‐
that's my setup.
I've been there.
O'Leary: Wow.
It's a good time.
My friends come over.
You're living the life.
I'm actually living it.
Like, even being here,
this is a great time.
I got to tell you, when you
pulled out the piece of paper
and said your customer
acquisition cost was $33,
how do you know that?
Because you haven't
sold anything
outside of
the Kickstarter.
So I'm looking at the amount
of money I made
and then how much it cost
in ad spend
to get those customers.
But that was
on the Kickstarter deal.
Kickstarter is ‐‐ is almost like
an unreal environment.
I want to know,
if we started today,
how much would it cost you
to go get a customer?
Okay.
Okay, but you realize
that the underwear business
is different
than the T‐shirt business
is different than
the sheet business.
Is different than
the sheet business, yeah.
But here ‐‐ the thing is
because when people come to me,
they're usually campers or,
like, people that
just don't like ‐‐
I get it.
But you're telling me
you're worth close
to 2 million bucks, okay?
Yeah.
So I have to try and figure out,
what is the business?
But this deal
has no structure yet.
I don't care about the underwear
and T‐shirt business.
Returns are horrific.
I agree. You're right.
So I would forget
about that.
The sheet thing
is intriguing, okay?
Doing sheets for men
with copper infusion
to stop them from rotting
in their own beds.
I love that story.
We don't know yet
the customer acquisition cost.
And so you can't
say to me
that you're worth
close to $2 million.
I don't buy it.
I mean, I said it,
but it might not be true.
I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
Cuban: Oh, my God.
So I mean ‐‐
O'Leary: It's ‐‐ It's one of
those "Shark Tank" moments.
Cuban: Wen,
I want to hang out with you.
I want to
hang out with you.
I'm just a guy having fun.
I'm from Africa, man.
Like, I'm going to tell you,
I'm from a village.
I'm a ‐‐
I'm from a small village.
Honestly, the fact I'm here,
to me, it's great.
This is a great time.
I'm so happy to be here.
Best pitch ever.
Wen, if the $2 million
isn't true...
Yeah.
...what number
do you think is true?
Well, my gosh. I mean...
[ Sighs ]
♪♪
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in.
The Sharks are charmed
by Wen's honesty,
but he still needs to answer
the tough questions
regarding his bedding company
for men, Jax Sheets.
Herjavec: If the $2 million
isn't true,
what number
do you think is true?
Well, my gosh.
Like, $1.8 million?
That's a fair number.
Cuban: Wen,
you're incredible.
Look, you are this business
and this business is you.
It's my baby.
Right? Your baby, right?
We would just corrupt it.
You're doing it exactly
the way you wanted to.
Every now and then,
somebody just hits it right
and gets a business
that fits them perfectly.
I don't want to kill your vibe.
I'm out.
Let me tell you
where I'm at.
Yes.
Couldn't love you more.
You know, we see people
that want something from us
all the time.
Mm‐hmm. Mm‐hmm.
Those people are honest
and they're sincere,
but sometimes they're not.
And when somebody comes out
that's pure and honest
and full of joy,
that's why we get so excited.
Yeah.
You are purity.
What you're not, though,
is an investable business today.
Kickstarter
is not a business.
You've got to go out
and actually get customers.
Yes.
You've got to go out
and build the business.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I can't invest in it.
I'm out.
I appreciate that.
Listen, Wen, I only like to deal
with entrepreneurs
that are honest
and real and up front,
and you are
that whole package.
And I see merit
to what you have.
It's almost like having
a really fantastic cellphone
without service.
Okay.
I feel like you have the premise
of a really good idea,
but I'm not sure
about the business,
so I'm out.
So here's what I think.
You're in three
different categories,
and they're
totally different.
And you're going to
need to learn
each one
of those businesses.
So that's ‐‐ that's
a little concerning.
Mm‐hmm.
But you can make
those decisions
when you don't have
a partner, right?
You can ‐‐ You can sit there
and say,
"I'mma do this
'cause I'mma test myself.
I'm going to do this
because I'm making money."
You can do that.
But in the ‐‐ in the event
things don't go well,
you're going to have partners
saying,
"Why are you outside
hanging out with your friends?"
I mean, that's what people
are going to say
when you have money at risk.
And you want to keep
your liberty right now
where you're at.
Okay.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
When COVID hit,
I told every one of my CEOs,
"Verify your customer
acquisition costs direct."
I got lots of chickens
in the coop right now
squawking for cash
because everybody's doing
the digital pivot.
And that's the one thing
I need to know.
Do you understand
your customer acquisition cost?
If you do,
Daddy has cash.
I want a return on it.
But you don't have that answer.
And so I'm sorry,
but I'm out.
You don't have what I need.
You're almost
the kind of guy
I'd love to see back here
with the data.
‐Love to.
‐Yes, absolutely.
I'd love to see you
back here.
Bring the data,
'cause you're such a nice guy.
Oh, man. Wow.
Good luck to you.
Now you have a goal.
Well, guys, you know,
like I said,
I do appreciate this.
And no matter what happens,
thank you guys
for having me here, honestly.
Good luck to you.
Good luck, man.
Greiner: You're welcome.
Thank you for presenting to us.
Thanks so much.
Congrats, man. You were amazing.
One of the best ever.
Is today a win or a loss?
Today's ‐‐ I mean,
every day is a win.
So whatever happens, I'm ‐‐
My name is Wen.
All I do is win.
So, like, there's nothing else
I can tell you.
Honestly, it's a win
every day of my life.
Narrator: In season 11,
Brett Ellenson
and David Sodemann
made a deal with
Barbara Corcoran
for Boho Camper Vans,
designer vans that you can buy
or rent.
Greiner: This looks, like,
totally fun.
Sodemann: We try to make it
look like a tiny home.
Narrator: Let's see what
they're up to now.
Sodemann: Airing on "Shark Tank"
right at the start
of the pandemic
was bittersweet.
Right away,
we had our two busiest months
completely cancel
on the rental side.
We were losing
thousands of dollars a day.
We weren't sure where
the business was going to go.
With our rentals
just sitting in our garage,
we saw an opportunity
to help.
We decided to donate our vans
to first responders in Phoenix
to just provide them a way
to get away from the hospital
and relax.
As the stay‐at‐home orders
started to lift,
we saw a massive influx
of renters coming back.
Boho Vans are perfect
for a pandemic
because they're self‐quarantined
by design.
It's a really great way
to travel right now.
One of the biggest issues
for our business
has been finding a reliable
source for cargo vans.
We've now partnered with a local
dealership for our clients
to purchase a van and turn it
into a Boho masterpiece.
In the year before "Shark Tank,"
we had done $493,000 in sales.
In the eight months
since "Shark Tank,"
we've done $1.4 million
in sales.
And we have another $1 million
of preorders on the way.
You've doubled your number
of employees.
You've tripled
your production.
It gives me every reason
to believe
that the sky's
the limit.
Corcoran:
Recreational vans of your own
that you can put your family in
and travel safely
anywhere you want in America
is not just a trend,
but it's the way of the future.
Today, customers are putting
health, safety, and value first.
So no matter
what business you're in,
you've got to
pivot your operation
to make sure
you're meeting their desires.
You're one of
the entrepreneurs
when I go to bed at night,
I don't worry about.
Sodemann: We started
Boho Camper Vans
because it's something
we truly enjoy.
We like to camp.
We like the outdoors.
It started from a passion.
Boho isn't just
a business anymore.
It's a way for people
to get outside,
spend time with their families,
spend time with their friends.
It feels good to be able
to provide that to people.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is an
innovation of a favorite food.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks,
my name is Michelle Jimenez,
and this is my husband.
Andrea Meggiato.
And we're here
from New York City.
We are seeking
a $125,000 investment
for 5% of our company.
Whoa.
Sharks,
who doesn't love pizza?
As we all know, there are
pizza lovers all over the world.
Pizza is delicious.
But when you think
of frozen pizza,
you don't think of it
as an appetizer
or a high‐quality
gourmet snack.
And let's be honest,
it can be hard
to eat those
delicious slices on the go.
Plus, the frozen pizza snacks
category has gone a bit stale.
But that is until now.
Both: Sharks,
meet the Pizza Cupcake.
Mamma mia!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
John:
It's your birthday.
Oh, yeah.
‐One, two, one, dip.
‐Oh, no. Don't knock ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
Pizza guy! That's it.
Get the hell out of here.
[ Laughter ]
The Pizza Cupcake
is the next level of pizza
that belongs anywhere
and everywhere.
A fine gourmet snack
that's easy to serve
and made
with high‐quality ingredients.
Plus our trade secret
dough recipe
delivers a fluffy texture
that's unlike any pizza
you've ever had.
And because of its cupcake shape
and size,
the Pizza Cupcake
is perfect for any occasion
and can be enjoyed
in even more ways and places
than your traditional slice.
So, Sharks, who's ready to
take a bite of...
Both: The Pizza Cupcake?
Hey!
Stop talking. Let's eat!
Yes!
Please dig in.
Which one
should we try?
So those are our two
best sellers,
the margherita
and the pepperoni.
So the margherita
is the vegetarian.
Pepperoni is, you know, is one
of the Americans' favorites.
Wow.
And the sauce
is your sauce?
The sauce is our sauce ‐‐
it's the marinara sauce
that we made just before
we came in.
‐This is delicious.
‐It's really good.
It's really good.
Thank you.
I hate you
'cause I want to eat these.
‐Me too.
‐Oh!
It's not
your regular pizza dough.
It's a ‐‐
It's a hybrid that we created.
Why is it so good,
so fluffy?
Greiner: It's like
a flaky pastry.
There's got to be
a lot of butter in this thing.
Exactly.
No, there is no butter.
‐What?
‐Only olive oil.
It's a hybrid between a brioche
and a sourdough.
So you get the fluffiness
of the brioche,
and then you get the crunchy
and the flakiness.
Oh, my God.
Andrea, how old is this?
Like, it tastes like you made it
this morning.
That's a frozen product.
Wow.
Yeah, we ship these
from New York City.
Yeah.
The marinara sauce
is our favorite.
‐Really good.
‐For Kevin to be silent
and just be eating
is amazing.
It's so good.
And it's 160 calories
for the margherita.
For one, right?
Yes. Yes, for one.
And 170
for the pepperoni.
Andrea, tell us
your background.
How did you come up
with this magic?
So I'm born and raised
in Venice, Italy,
and I worked in the kitchen
as a chef since I was 16.
And I moved to London
to learn English
when I was 19 years old.
And in London, I worked for one
of the fine Italian restaurants
that is owned by one of the
largest private members clubs
in ‐‐ in the world.
Soho?
Soho House, yeah.
And they gave me the opportunity
to move to New York
in 2006 to open
one of their members' clubs.
And I spent 10 years doing that
until I met Michelle.
How did you meet Michelle?
So we met through
a mutual friend,
and it was really funny
because he asked me out
on a pizza date.
And I said, "Pizza date?
No man has ever asked me out
for pizza."
But the twist was he wanted
to teach me how to make pizza.
I'm sure he did.
I had to show off.
Yeah, he had to show off.
And we've been married
for almost two years now.
And this is our first baby.
Congratulations.
You know,
I was an event producer
and then I worked
with social media influencers.
Herjavec: And how did you go
from this incredible product
you're making to actually
launching the business?
Walk us through that.
Actually, there was one event
that we did
that it was for
our best friends.
It was all a group
of Italian people,
and everybody loved it.
And, you know,
Italians are picky.
So I was like ‐‐ we were afraid,
but they all loved it.
And she, with her, you know,
background, she was like,
"We need to bring this
to my events
and see
what the reaction is."
And that's how we started.
How do you sell it?
Yeah, so ‐‐ so right now
we sell direct to consumer.
But last year,
our three distribution channels
were catering,
Smorgasburg,
which is New York City's
most popular market.
That gave us the street cred,
you know,
to really have
that proof of concept.
And then
we also did stadiums.
So our first partnership
was with Citi Field,
home of the New York Mets,
and they actually approached us.
Did you get
a commercial kitchen involved?
Yes, we produce
in a commercial kitchen,
and we also have a co‐packer
who we've been working with
for the last nine months.
Lori, you might be familiar
with our co‐packer.
We definitely
sought them out
because their biggest client
is Bantam Bagel.
‐Yeah.
‐What will sales be this year?
So this year we're projecting
$800,000 in sales.
‐Wow. Good for you.
‐Ooh, very nice.
We did $344,000
in revenue last year.
Year to date,
we've done $77,000.
But we have a plan and we know
how to execute our plan.
So, prior to COVID, we were
really a restaurant business.
And so because of
the seasonality of our business,
we knew that we had
to launch e‐commerce.
Direct to customer
frozen product.
Correct. Yes,
direct to customer.
That's tough.
We knew that was
in the roadmap,
because currently
we're New York City‐based.
Our customers are from
all around the country,
and they wanted to know
where they could find us.
I learned something with
Wicked Good Cupcakes.
Yes.
The first royalty deal
in "Shark Tank" history
just paid its millionth dollar
to me in royalties.
Wow.
Fantastic.
But the shipping journey
we took
and the cost of the weight of
cupcake jars made of glass,
we learned we had to sell six,
not three.
Then we went to a dozen.
Our goal right now is to find
a different fulfillment center
who can serve us,
one in the Midwest,
one in the Northeast,
and one in the South.
Greiner: Right.
But what do you charge,
Michelle? What is this?
12 come in this.
So a 12 pack is $24.99.
And how much is shipping?
$9.99.
35 bucks.
So $35 to get 12 pizzas.
Correct, and ‐‐
Cuban:
It's 3 bucks a cupcake.
What does it cost you
to make these?
One cupcake is 95 cents
at the moment.
That's expensive.
Yeah, that's expensive.
O'Leary: Wow.
It is expensive because
we're making it by hand
in our commercial kitchens.
The recipe that we have
allow us to go
to 48 cents per cupcake.
And that's why we're here
for your investment
so we can start production
with our co‐packer.
You're starting up.
You haven't even figured out
yet, you know,
how it's all
going to come together
in terms of shipping
a frozen product.
I think you're going to have
some significant challenges.
There's no question about it.
Good luck to you.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Here's where I'm at, guys.
I'm not even going
to get into the valuation
because you could
be optimistic.
Really, I just think that
I don't know
if I'd be the greatest partner.
Soon as I saw this,
I was like,
"This is Bantam Bagels
in another category."
I know other people up here
who have stadiums
and a bunch of buddies
with stadiums.
Yeah, with no one
showing up right now.
But they will sooner
or later, right?
Eventually, yes.
Yes.
So I really wish you
all the best,
but in the best interest
of being a good Shark for you,
I'm not the best partner
up here.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Thank you, Daymond.
Herjavec:
Look, I'm really torn.
I think you're going
to get a better offer
than I probably
would've made you.
But, man, you guys are
the real deal.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Greiner: First off, I think
it's amazingly delicious.
I mean, listen, you're from
Venice and you're from New York.
You guys know what you're doing
when it comes to pizza.
Um, I'm going to
make you an offer
because I think there's
really great synergy
with my Bantam Bagels company.
Yes.
So Bantam Bagels,
as you know,
started with
a stuffed bagel ball,
and we got into Starbucks
nationwide,
and then we got into
all the major grocery stores,
freezer sections.
So that might be fun for them
to also be involved.
Come on, Lori,
you're making me hungry.
So I'm going to
make you an offer.
I'm going to offer you
$125,000,
but for 20%.
Ooh.
[ Cuban laughs ]
Mamma mia!
♪♪
Narrator: Three Sharks are out.
Michelle and Andrea have
an offer on the table from Lori
for their business,
The Pizza Cupcake,
but she wants a bigger slice
of the pie
than the 5%
they came in offering.
I'm going to offer you
$125,000,
but for 20%.
Ooh.
[ Cuban laughs ]
Mamma mia!
What we can bring to the table
is worth it.
I think that we can help you
to skyrocket.
Ouch.
It's like a mob offer.
I'll be ‐‐ No, it's not at all.
It's a great offer.
I could have gone higher,
actually.
I mean, you have an offer.
That's pretty interesting.
Yes, no, thank you so much
for the offer.
Well, you can follow
in our footsteps
of every single distribution
channel that we have.
Mark?
Yeah, guys, I mean, look,
if you want to stay frozen,
working with Bantam
is the way to go.
Here's the thing, right?
Selling frozen is hard,
as Lori will tell you,
as we've all done.
Getting the space
is really hard.
Getting it to deliver at a
reasonable price is really hard.
And so for those reasons.
I'm out.
But congratulations, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Well, you're ‐‐ you're left
with Lori.
And, yes, no Lori,
20% is too high for us.
I feel like we've already gone
through a lot of challenges.
We found the co‐packer,
which I think is
the most difficult part.
Would you be willing to do
$125,000 for 10%?
We work really hard.
You really wouldn't have to do
a lot of heavy lifting.
We have investors on board
who are also really strategic.
We've been in conversations with
one of the largest distributors
right now
who wants us to participate
in their incubator program
to get us into retail.
I know
the time and effort
and all of that
that we will put in.
I know you're going to do
the heavy lifting,
but I know that I will also be
opening so many doors for you.
If I can get you
into Starbucks nationwide...
Yes.
...that's 9,000 locations.
And then getting into Kroger,
Albertsons,
it will be
so worth it to you.
I will not go to 10%.
My bottom line ‐‐
My bottom line would be 15%.
♪♪
Would you do $125,000
for 12.5%, Lori? Please?
‐[ Chuckles ]
‐You know what?
I love you, but, listen,
you will love me.
15%.
I got ‐‐ You want me to be
invested in you
and you want me
to work hard.
Would you be willing
to go up
to $150,000
for 15%?
$125,000, 15%,
and I promise you,
you will not regret it.
So Bantam Bagel,
you invested
at a $1.1 million valuation
when they were on the show.
And we have higher revenue
than them.
Ohh.
And we also have figured out
our co‐packer situation.
We also have ‐‐ You know,
we're shipping...
Herjavec:
Boom. You go, Michelle.
...direct to consumer.
And we ‐‐ And we ‐‐
I think our marketing
is much stronger.
It's okay
to stick to your guns.
You know what, you guys?
I completely ‐‐
I completely
understand it.
But here's something
you don't know.
You said you were
learning the ropes, right?
What I know is, is that there's
so much more for you to learn.
And the thing that is invaluable
is learning experience.
I had no mentor. I had to figure
out everything for myself.
But I do know that somebody
could come and sit with me
for just one day,
and I could save them two years'
worth of time, of mistakes.
Also the connections.
Guys, you sound like
you're students of "Shark Tank."
You know your numbers.
I got that.
But you also know something else
about "Shark Tank."
When you only have
one offer...
Yes.
...you're skating
on really thin ice.
Yes, we know.
And now you have to
make a decision.
No, I know. Um...
Can I make
one more counteroffer?
Ohh!
You can do
whatever you like.
Would you be willing to do
$125,000 for 12.5%
and then 2.5%
in advisory shares?
Lori, what do you say?
You got a deal.
Yes!
‐Yay!
‐Congratulations.
‐High‐five.
‐Alright, Shark hug.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you so much.
Make sure my pizza is
at my house by this weekend.
Herjavec: Arrivederci,
pizza guy.
Jimenez: We're living that
American dream
where we have
our family business,
we have our dream Shark
on our team,
and we can just
really start scaling
and, you know,
having Pizza Cupcakes
as a household brand.
♪♪
Narrator: Next up is a solution
to a headache for many people.
♪♪
Ah!
Ah‐ha!
Hey, Sharks,
my name's Nic Lamb.
I'm from Santa Cruz, California,
and I'm here seeking
$50,000
in exchange for 20%
of my company, IceBeanie.
Sharks, as you may
be able to tell,
I spend most of my time chasing
the largest surf on the planet.
I'm a professional
big wave surfer.
Started surfing at 5,
competing at 9.
Wow.
At 14, I became the youngest
to ever surf Mavericks.
Only a few years later,
I'm now the current defending
Mavericks champion. Whoo!
But while surfing
Nazaré, Portugal,
the largest wave in the world,
I slipped and fell
on a giant 70‐foot wave
that rung my bell and left me
with a serious concussion.
Oh, ohh.
Now, for months
after the incident,
I had terrible post‐concussion
migraine headaches.
So frustrated with holding
ice packs on my head,
I knew there had to be
a better way.
That's why
I created IceBeanie.
IceBeanie is an all‐natural
compression cold therapy
solution
to help provide you
heavenly relief
from migraines, headaches,
and concussions.
Simply toss IceBeanie
in the freezer,
take out,
and place on your head.
It's that easy!
So, guys, do you
or a loved one suffer
from debilitating
migraine headaches?
Are you tired of holding
the frozen bag of peas
on your head
or over‐the‐counter drugs?
It's time to take back control
of your life with IceBeanie!
So, guys,
who's ready to get cool
and invest with IceBeanie?
Greiner: Good job.
‐You're right.
‐Thank you.
Nic, was that the wave
that knocked you out?
It was, yeah.
If we could get a replay,
you can see me actually
getting sucked over the falls.
This is it?
There I go. Yeah. Trying to
balance on the ocean.
‐Oh, it's okay to fall.
‐Oh, my God.
See me get sucked over?
Cuban:
That's got to hurt.
Greiner: Wow.
I popped up and got a quick
little breath to survive.
How tall was that wave?
Six‐, seven‐story building.
60, 70 foot.
You know, but ‐‐
‐You are crazy, man.
How hard is that impact?
I love it.
It's like
an underwater car accident.
It's pretty intense.
You know, it's like NASCAR
meets the ocean, but I love it.
So I have a question
about this.
Yes.
So I know people
who have migraines,
and, you know, I've seen people
put things on their heads...
Sure.
...that have ice in them.
Are you
the only thing out there
with ice packs in it
that are a cap?
So what I can tell you is
that there's nothing like
IceBeanie on the market.
Now,
there are other products.
However,
they are bulky, heavy,
do not all provide
full head coverage,
and all of them require
an arduous setup.
IceBeanie addresses
all those pain points.
That's why we feel we're not
only different, but better.
Are you saying that
the other ones
have packs like this
in them?
Some of them
have gel inserts, yeah,
but they all ‐‐
you have to
apply them to the ‐‐
to the product.
‐Is this patented?
‐So you don't have
a patent on this.
We're patent pending.
It doesn't fit.
So you got to pull it ‐‐
pull it down, Robert.
John: Yes, it goes ‐‐
it goes just around.
It's polyester.
So, yeah.
It goes just around.
It doesn't have the center part.
As the ice warms up
from your head...
Greiner: How does that feel?
Does it feel really cold?
It feels good.
Actually,
it feels really good.
Feels really good.
And your head will warm it up,
and it'll start to mold
to the shape of your head.
Does it grow hair?
[ Laughs ]
I'm trying to get my head
around it so to speak, Nic.
How big a market is there
for people that want
to put ice hats on their heads?
In the US alone,
there's over 40 million people
that suffer from migraines,
and over a billion worldwide.
But how many would actually
wrap their head in ice?
That's the question.
Cuban: Anybody who thought
it would work would do it.
Yeah, absolutely.
Well ‐‐
Yeah, tell us about your
business and how it's working.
Yeah. Absolutely.
So the unit economics,
we source for $7
and sell for $39.95.
And where
do you sell them?
Right now,
we're selling direct to consumer
off our website,
Amazon, and Etsy.
Cool.
And how many have you sold
over what period of time?
So we launched
near Q4 last year.
Sales to date
are just around $100,000.
Way more than
I would have thought.
2,500 units.
Greiner: And what was your mode
of getting it out there
for people
to know about it?
Right, so we've been leveraging
a network of influencers
that I have ‐‐
professional UFC athletes,
CrossFit world champions,
actresses,
and Olympic gold medalists.
And why are they wearing it?
What's their purpose?
Well, they wear it
after intense workouts.
I use it now more after,
like, an intense workout.
It's like cold therapy
for your head.
You know, and, yeah, really,
because I can see that,
like, instead of pouring water
on your head
or putting a towel on your neck
or one of those things.
I can see this
cooling you down.
Exactly.
It's cold therapy
for your head.
O'Leary:
I moved to Florida
so my head didn't feel like this
in the winter ‐‐
I got to tell you.
Herjavec: And your average
consumer that buys it,
are they buying it,
like Mark said, for a workout?
Are they buying it
for migraines?
Do you have any data
around that?
Primarily they're buying it
for migraines, headaches.
And some of our customers
have had TBI,
traumatic brain injury...
Huh.
...as well as
chemotherapy customers,
because I believe
going through the therapy...
Yeah, 'cause I can see that
for chemo.
...their heads get hot.
Yes.
Wow.
I didn't think about that.
O'Leary:
Nic, it's interesting.
I'm very impressed by you.
I really, really thought
you were nuts
when you walked in here.
But you have
a clear plan.
It's just the size
of the market.
I think it's going
to be difficult
to acquire customers
to scale it.
This is my own opinion
because
a certain kind of person
will put ice on their head.
Finding that person
is not that easy.
But there's multiple markets,
right,
such as
the hospital market,
we have the sport market,
and then the hangover market,
you know?
Look, I wish you the best.
For me,
this is just not some‐‐
a journey I want to surf with.
So I'm out.
Alright. Thank you.
So, Nic, you had a problem,
you came up with a solution,
but I'm very dubious
about investing in this
because I'm concerned
about your competition.
Sure.
So while you're great
and this is great ‐‐
I'm not afraid
of competition.
I know. And you know what?
You're going to do amazing,
because you have
that drive within you.
I just don't think it's
the right investment for me.
Okay.
So I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Thank you.
♪♪
Cuban: You know what?
I'll make you an offer,
because for 50 grand,
you're a great partner.
It's a great idea.
Worst case, I can get them
in the Mavs locker room.
That would be fantastic.
So I'll give ‐‐
I'll give you the 50K.
I want 30%.
Would you go to 25%,
Mark?
Done.
‐Nice.
‐I'll give you a hug.
Whoo!
We can't touch, right?
So are you sure you didn't want
to hear my offer?
Daymond...
Cuban:
Appreciate it, Nic, man.
We never heard
from Robert.
I had a great offer.
You never gave Robert
a chance.
Did you?
Oh, I don't believe you.
It looked like you were out.
Yeah, I don't believe him,
either.
No, no, I had a great offer.
I just think you were going
down the wrong road.
You just fell off
another seven‐story wave.
Cuban: Oh, no, no, no.
And you fell
into a money pit.
My man. Exactly. Yes.
So, there you go.
We're gonna do really well.
I think I would have liked
to have heard Robert's offer.
No, who cares
what Robert's offer is?
O'Leary: Well, it might have
been a better offer.
I think ‐‐
A lesson learned here ‐‐ You did
not allow price discovery, Nic.
What do you mean? You just made
the deal of a lifetime.
John: Nic ‐‐
I just closed a deal.
I'm pretty happy.
Nic, Nic, Nic, hold on.
You know, people come out,
they get excited.
I get it. You should never
take the first offer, my friend.
[ Chuckling ] Oh.
If it's from the right partner,
you always say yes.
Greiner: Nic, you could
change your mind
and hear
what they have to say.
♪♪
I'm going to ‐‐ I'm going to
take the offer
that I have from Mark.
I'm super happy.
When it's the right offer,
you can always say yes.
Thank you guys
for your time.
You can open it back up
right now.
‐No, he can't.
‐Is that how it works?
Rules are made
to be broken.
Cuban: No!
I'll give you $100,000
for 25%.
Oh!
See what you left
on the table?
♪♪
I accepted Mark's offer.
I have to honor that.
Absolutely.
I'm so excited.
Exactly right.
Appreciate it, Nic.
Good answer.
You're not a scumbag.
Congratulations.
You made the wrong deal,
but I wish you all the best.
O'Leary: Nic, you won't be ‐‐
Thank you, guys.
Appreciate you.
Cuban: He's been saying that
for 11 years.
Greiner: Bye, Nic.
Thanks, guys.
Whoo! You guys snooze,
you lose.
We were waiting.
Whoo‐hoo‐hoo‐hoo!
I jumped
on Mark's offer
because when you get an
opportunity like that in life,
you seize it.
You don't wait.
You just jump on it
and seize the opportunity.
And that's what I did.
And I couldn't be happier.
Oh, yeah!
Hyah!
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a way
to get that draft beer taste
from a can.
♪♪
What's up, Sharks?
My name is Pat.
And my name is Armand,
and we are seeking $300,000
in exchange for 10%
of our company.
Pat, you know what I love more
than anything? Draft beer.
There's just something about it
that tastes way better
than beer in a can.
Bro, it's because you can
actually smell
the beer you're drinking
rather than the aluminum top.
True, but in most places,
cans are the only option,
and they're not
going anywhere.
Yeah, when I go
camping and fishing,
I only bring cans, but I usually
just pour into a cup.
Dude, plastic cups
are such a waste.
There has to be
a better way.
Alright.
How about this?
What if we just remove
the entire top of the can?
Oh, you mean like this?
Sharks, don't try this
at home.
[ Groans ]
Greiner: Oh, my God.
Bro, stop.
Sharks, we know
there's a better way
to experience
canned beverages.
That's why
we created Draft Top,
the only patented bar tool
on the market
that's designed to remove
the top of your canned beverage
and turn it into a cup.
Beer me, brochacho.
Here's how it works.
Open the handle.
Place Draft Top on the can.
Squeeze and rotate.
O'Leary: Whoa.
It's that easy.
And not to mention the top
is removed from the inside rim,
leaving...
Both: No sharp edges.
So, Sharks,
who's ready to...
drink topless?
Drink topless?
Herjavec:
What am I doing wrong?
Why can't I get this to work?
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hold on. Hold on.
We're gonna walk you
through that.
So, in front of you,
we got a fancy version
of the customized tools
for you.
You can open it by pressing here
on top of the handle.
Just pull it out like that?
You got it.
Once in the open position,
you're going to place
the tool on the can.
Alright. You're going to
wiggle out just a little bit.
Once you get on, you're going
to squeeze the handle
just slightly until
the handle ‐‐
the handle compresses.
Wait.
Greiner: Aah!
It didn't work.
John: Hold on, guys. Hold on.
We're having a little...
Did you get it to work?
My problem is I'm crushing
the can while I'm doing it.
It usually takes
a couple beers
to get the ‐‐
get the trick down.
It's too complicated.
Well, I have a question
for you.
Sure.
Obviously, it was a little
challenging here for us.
I made a mess.
How many
have you sold?
Yeah, so we've had the product
selling for eight months now,
and we've sold $1.6 million.
‐What?
‐Yes, sir! Yes, sir!
Selling over
70,000 units.
Oh, now we're interested
in this.
‐Alright. Now we're talking.
‐Seriously?
So in December,
we did crowdfunding,
and we did $835,000 in sales
on crowdfunding.
John: Oh, there you go.
That's it.
So this was our second time
on Kickstarter.
Lifetime sales are a little
over $2 million.
‐Hey, guys.
‐Yeah?
So ‐‐ So ‐‐
Guys, look, I may be dumb,
but I'm not stupid, right?
If I'm having
all this trouble,
what were the reviews
on Kickstarter?
What's the feedback?
So we've had a lot
of great reviews
and we've had others that didn't
necessarily feel as well.
But what we've done is we know
there's a consumer ‐‐
You mean they're not so great.
Yeah, but surprisingly,
not as much as you would think.
But we put out a lot of content
on social media and YouTube
where we have training videos
and stuff.
Look, guys, I can see this being
a great gag gift,
a great, you know,
groomsman gift,
but at the end of the day,
I can't even get it to work.
So we do tell the consumer there
is a bit of a learning curve.
So there is
an expectation ‐‐
Yeah, but listen ‐‐
listen to that. Listen to that.
Listen to what
you're telling me.
You're asking me
to waste a beer.
And that is never tolerable.
So you don't actually need
to waste a beer.
And for those reasons,
I'm out.
Mark, you don't need to
waste a beer.
We tell people to ‐‐
to start with empties.
So collect
a couple empties.
Practice
with my empties?
Yeah, absolutely.
It works the same way.
There you go. Well...
You sold $2 million
worth of it.
That's serious money, okay?
Yeah.
My question is why?
Why does
the world need this?
Alright.
It's ‐‐ It's a fun item,
but it's not worth $3 million.
Guys. Guys, I‐I've tried
four times now.
I tried it slowly.
I took the thing down.
I h‐held it.
I put on the thing.
I can't get it to work.
I'm out.
Okay. Okay.
Thank you, Robert.
Thank you.
Guys, I've been here really
trying to work the can, okay...
Sure. Okay.
...trying to understand the
excitement about the product.
I get it.
Yeah.
But it ‐‐ it's such
a pain in the heinie.
I mean, I was going to
look at it and say,
"Okay, do you have any
flexibility on valuation?"
[ Laughter ]
So ‐‐
Of course we do.
Did you figure that
your experience here
would go like that,
with all of us laughing?
No, actually, no.
We ‐‐ I do want to talk
about our sales.
Yeah. I want to talk
about that, too.
Okay. Okay.
What does it cost
for you to make it?
And what do you sell it at?
It's $14.13‐‐
I'm sorry ‐‐
$4.13 to make it.
It's 100% American made.
‐Nice.
‐Wow.
We sell it for $24.99
direct from the website.
‐That's expensive.
‐Oh, there you go.
Cuban: That's good margins.
You have a patent,
right?
Utility patent, yep.
Okay.
Hell yeah. Got you.
[ Laughs ]
Greiner: You did it by
three beers. So there you go.
Alright.
So our biggest ‐‐
Our biggest problem
is inventory, right?
We can't keep up through
the website right now.
Our sales have dropped in half
in the last three weeks
because we just
can't make it fast enough.
Wow.
You guys, listen,
I‐I love innovation.
I love when people come up
with new ideas and things.
You know, obviously,
people like your concept, right?
Yes.
You have proof of sales.
You did amazing.
My problem is
we all had trouble using it.
That's not to say
you can't fix it,
but for me to invest $300,000,
no matter what percent,
on something
that needs tweaking,
it's not there yet.
And so I'm sorry.
I'm out.
Wow.
Daymond, Kevin?
Guys, I ‐‐ I think the mistake
was the 300K.
So, Kevin, we are on target to
do $3.2 million conservatively.
We think we'll be at $4 million
by the end of the year.
$300,000,
when I first saw it,
I said to myself, "Why?"
And I'm still here
looking at it, saying "Why?"
I'm just trying
to open a can.
I'm out.
Daymond.
‐Daymond.
‐Then there was one.
We've got 83% gross margins
on the product,
50% net margin.
We've got about a half
a million dollars in the bank.
We need a mentor
that can help us.
You know, I think there's
something missing here.
You're not seeing the pride
in what you've accomplished.
This is not a small
accomplishment.
Cuban:
It's really good, guys.
Why do you want a Shark?
What do you expect exactly?
I think they want
the $300,000.
No, we don't need the money
because we've got
a half a million dollars
in cash.
We need to know ‐‐
So if you don't
want the money,
then why did you valuate it
so high for the opportunity?
This is just what we felt
we valued this company at.
And it's a starting point.
We're going to finish this year
at $3 million.
Yeah. This is...
We plan to do at least
$6 million next year.
We need some guidance.
Why did you price it so high,
guys?
Because
it's just a starting point.
It is what we are going
to finish the year off at.
Did you ‐‐ Did you price it
so high
'cause maybe you don't
want a deal?
Not at all. Nope.
Okay.
I wanted to make sure.
Not at all.
We came here
for a partnership.
I mean, listen,
you want $300,000 for 10%.
I'm going to give you $300,000
for 20%.
Greedy.
♪♪
Herjavec:
Great offer, Daymond.
♪♪
Daymond, we're going
to take that offer.
Yes! Alright!
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you go!
I can't ‐‐ I can't ‐‐
You want me to
open that for you?
Let me try to celebrate.
Try it again.
I'm gonna try it one more time,
guys, alright?
O'Leary:
Ain't gonna work.
Nice and slow,
nice and slow.
Get it on there.
There you go.
‐Rotate, rotate.
‐There you go!
‐Whoo!
‐Go, Daymond, go, Daymond.
‐Oh. [ Laughs ]
‐Ohh.
Too bad they don't
put champagne in cans.
You know what?
We'll figure it out.
We're gonna give you
some training.
Because you know what?
The fun part, I get it.
Pat, Armand, cheers.
Thank you very much.
‐Congratulations, guys.
‐Thank you, guys.
Mazel tov.
Cheers, guys.
‐Cheers, Daymond.
‐Thank you.
‐Cheers!
‐Outstanding.
Greiner: Congrats.
Well, didn't exactly go
as expected,
but that was pretty good.
Cheers.
Daymond,
it doesn't work.
It does work.
Look at mine.
Let's see if
Mark can do it.
[ Clicking ]
You hear that?
You're crushing the can.
Greiner: Keep going. Keep going.
You hear that?
You're crushing the can.
Crushing the can.
Is it off? No.
Yes, it is.
Crushing the can.
But you had to push it in.
That's the way you do it.
You don't lift it out?
No.
Oh, you push it down.
Why didn't I push it in?
Ohh.
John: Yeah, you push it down.
Mine worked.
♪♪